walk him to this video playing sepia one
from Italy and again oh no I thought I
thought I had some names or games
against them but we get the field shetow
here yeah the Queen a firefly sometimes
causing the Cavalla variation you go h3r
look you want I don't know yeah black
here always must decide if and when he
wants to check on deform I am oh that's
that's uncommon I mean in general the
idea I'm not really familiar with the
specific position I don't normally I
don't like d5 very much maybe I can just
protect the c-4 upon its it's not so
clear what is next move is 9075 it's not
it's not really great so let's see
maybe I can play simply here I don't
have that began big of an experience yet
with the fianchetto radiation trying
this out in in recent games IAM wanting
some alternative to my usual classical
king's indian like the mcconnell
variation and others um okay
I can I can drive the Queen bag
just keep the tension if it takes Knight
X this should always be a quite ok
structure ok is retreating this ok
should I just go back I don't know 93
before is a bit under bit under pressure
yeah I guess so let's retreat this
Bishop on the two does not look very
great now maybe you can go back a queen
bee six but then c5 Nelson and c5 gets
very interesting queen bee 65 D takes d5
the night only has the h5 square and
might be trapped after for the g4 ok is
taken I briefly thought that maybe I
yeah there's some tactic may be
available interesting if i move the
night maybe 95 mmm but it does not have
any any square does it
if I go here and the night goes to e5
after f4 it has no square
okay so it's just just retreating and
now Bishop f4 maybe just asking him what
he's doing with this this is Pawn
nothing it's doing nothing with the pond
okay Bishop e7 first or just see 5c five
should be good on gaining the space it's
also a five
hmm
yakima its let's make sure this Bishop
is very securely protected mighty for
you now this starts to look very nice no
we should only six is terrible for him I
mean terrible to play against okay just
f form
oh no no no I cannot believe that I can
take back resign yeah I have not yet
decided what to do I can take I can take
f6 and this is the easiest if I thought
that maybe this this diagonal also ism
we look here this diagonal there's an
issue but it's it's it's easiest just to
take him to get this get this and this
was an opening opening disaster yeah I
don't know this is maybe still okay in a
way
computer says that night c5 is good for
blanket maybe maybe I'm not very well
coordinated yes I cannot go Bishop g2
year because of 93 mmmm then he for is a
problem and I need to play an ugly move
like this that's not good okay this was
what you should have done and this is
I'm not really sure about I mean here
now I just need to retreat now it's
basically losing the pawn is it not yeah
this was a this was a particularly bad
way to give it up I mean probably poor
maybe maybe you can still play here
counter-attacking you form after after
night age 5 and the capture black is
basically lost i think i just i just
keep keep the material and have this
oops oops have this this big center ya
here mi just winning he has no counter
play so avalanche of pawns running over
black okay thanks for watching